what could you do to improve yourself
well let's step one step backwards the
first question might be why should you
even bother improving yourself
the answer to that is something like so
you don't suffer any more stupidly than
you have to
and maybe so others don't have to either
it's something like that you know like
there's a real injunction at the bottom
of it it's not some casual self-help
doctrine it's that if you don't organize
yourself properly you'll pay for it and
in a big way and so will the people
around you and you could say well i
don't care about that but that's
actually not true you actually do care
about that because if you're in pain you
will care about it it's very rare that
you can find someone who's in
excruciating pain who would ever say
well it would be no better if i was out
of this well so then the question might
be well how would you go about getting
your act together and the answer to that
it's something like
look around for something that bothers
you and see if you can fix it
you can do this in a room it's quite fun
to do it just when you're sitting in a
room like a room maybe your bedroom you
can sit there and just sort of meditate
on and think okay if i wanted to spend
10 minutes making this room better
what would i have to do and you have to
ask yourself that right it's not a
command it's like a genuine question and
things will pop out in the room there's
a stack of papers over there that's kind
of bugging you and you know that maybe a
little order there would be a good thing
and there's some rubbish behind your
computer monitor that you haven't
attended to for like six months and if
you allow yourself just to consider the
expanse in which you exist at that
moment there'll be all sorts of things
that'll pop out in it that you could
just fix
you fix a hundred things like that
your life will be a lot different
now i often tell people to fix the
things you repeat every day because
people tend to think of those as trivial
right
you get up you brush your teeth you have
your breakfast you know you have your
routines that you go through every day
well those probably constitute 50
percent of your life and people think
well they're mundane i don't need to pay
attention to them it's like no no that's
exactly wrong the things you do every
day
those are the most important things you
do
hands down
once you've got your mind and your
emotions together and once you're acting
that out then you can
extend what you're willing to consider
yourself
and start fixing up the things
that are part of your broader extent
your mind is a very strange thing as
soon as you give it a name
a genuine aim it'll reconfigure the
world in keeping with that aim that
that's actually how you see to begin
with and so if you set it a task
you have to be genuine about it which is
why you have to bring your
thoughts and emotions together and then
you have to get them in your body so
you're acting consistently you have to
be genuine about the aim but once you
aim the world will reconfigure itself
around that aim which is very strange
you see what you aim at one
inference you might draw from that is be
careful what you aim at
what you aim at determines the way the
world manifests itself to you and so if
the world is manifesting itself
in a very negative way
one thing to ask is are you aiming at
the right thing now you know i'm not
trying to reduce everybody's problems to
an improper aim
there's a random element to being that's
for sure but it's still a great thing to
ask
ask and it shall be given you seek and
ye shall find knock and it shall be
opened unto you for everyone that asketh
receiveth and he that seeketh findeth
and to him that knocketh it shall be
opened
people's lives aren't what they would
like them to be
and so then you ask why
well forget about tragedy and
catastrophe
because that's self-evident and we're
not going to discuss that
but one of the main reasons that people
don't get what they want is because they
don't actually figure out what it is
and the probability that you're going to
get what would be good for you let's say
which would even be better than what you
want right because you know you might be
wrong about what you want easily but
maybe you could get what would really be
good for you well why don't you because
you don't try
you don't think okay here's what i would
like if i could have it and and i don't
mean
in a way that you manipulate the world
to force it to deliver you goods for
status or something like that that isn't
what i mean i mean something like
imagine that you were taking care of
yourself like you were someone you
actually cared for
and then you thought okay i'm caring for
this person i would like things to go as
well for them as possible what would
their life have to be like in order for
that to be the case
well people don't do that they don't sit
down and think all right you know let's
let's figure it out you've got a life
it's hard obviously it's like
three years from now you can have what
you need
you got to be careful about it you can't
have everything you can have what would
be good for you but you have to figure
out what it is and then you have to aim
at it
well my experience with people has been
is if they figure out what it is that
would be good for them and then they aim
at it then they get it
and it's strange because they don't it's
a strange thing it's not quite that
simple because
you know you may formulate an idea about
what would be good for you and then you
take 10 steps towards that and you find
out that your formulation was a bit off
and so you have to reformulate your goal
but a huge part of the reason that
people fail is because they don't ever
set up the criteria for success
and so since success is a very narrow
line and very unlikely the probability
that you're going to stumble on it
randomly is zero and so there's a
proposition here and the proposition is
if you actually want something
you can have it
now the question then would be what do
you mean by actually want and the answer
is that you reorient your life
in every possible way
to make the probability that that will
occur as certain as possible
you could try this
sit on your bed one day and ask yourself
what remarkably stupid things am i doing
on a regular basis to absolutely screw
up my life
and if you actually ask that question
but you have to want to know the answer
right because that's actually what
asking the question means it doesn't
mean just mouthing the words it means
you have to decide that you want to know
you'll figure that's out so fast it'll
make your hair curl
socrates said that the thing that made
him different than everyone else in
greece was that he consulted his demon
his genius he asked himself how it was
that he should conduct himself in the
world and then he did that whatever it
was he didn't try to force a solution
you know he didn't try to force a
solution selfishly he asked i'm going to
manifest myself in the best possible
manner in the world i would like to do
that
what would that be
what would happen if you consulted
yourself about the best possible outcome
for you
you might get an answer well that's what
this proposition is
[Music]
you